months late the cdc finally announces
that those who have been vaccinated can
take off their masks
joe biden continues his war on
teleprompters and israel pulls one of
the great military misdirects in modern
history i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn why haven't you gotten a vpn
yet visit expressvpn.com
to do so okay so you can take off your
mask if you're vaccinated
well who's been telling you that for
months on end who's been saying that
but every time we have said that for
months on end we have worried that
youtube will take down our videos or
that apple will somehow
censor us or that facebook will hit us
with a fact check why well because
your public health experts have been
lying to you see here is the thing and
this has been a thing throughout the
pandemic
science is a process science is rooted
in data
it's rooted in hypotheses which are then
either falsified or held up
by the data science is not in fact a
group of quote unquote
tusk scientists okay it is not a it's
not an institution
science is not anthony fauci science is
not rochelle wallensky science is not
any of these jokers
science is a process of verifying truth
or falsity
and so those of us who have been looking
at the data all along knew
that once you are vaccinated and you are
two weeks past your final vaccination
you don't need to wear a mask anymore
in fact in these very offices i was very
into masking because i didn't want to
infect my parents
i was very masking up until the point at
which they got vaccinated and i got
vaccinated
and at that point i said to everyone in
the offices if you don't want to wear a
mask
and you have the option to get
vaccinated if you choose not to get
vaccinated
that's a you problem if you choose to
wear a mask that's a you problem
once you're vaccinated you don't have to
care i've been saying this for months
you know why because i read the studies
you know why because i followed the data
you know why because i didn't listen to
the dullards
in the public health establishment who
have been infected with politics we were
told for a year
that donald trump infused all of his
coveted response with politics
and they pointed to his supposed
pressure on the cdc which the cdc denied
and they pointed to his so-called
pressure on anthony fauci without you
which fought she denied
okay and then joe biden came into office
and the
the entire public health establishment
just started mirroring whatever joe
biden wanted politically
they started going soft on whether
schools should reopen even though the
data said that schools
should be open they started suggesting
that vaccines weren't all that effective
they started suggesting that
workplaces should continue to socially
distance even after people have been
vaccinated joe biden was appearing
publicly
20 000 feet away from anybody outdoors
and he was still masking kamala harris
was kissing her husband
on tarmacs through a mask even though
both of them had been vaccinated
none of this was in compliance with
science all of it
was politically driven bullcrap because
as i said the goal of the biden
administration
was to gin up a feeling of panic and un
and unease
and unrest so that they could foster all
this massive
government growth the idea was that if
we are in the middle of a crisis then we
still need
more government and that of course was
using every crisis as an opportunity and
if the crisis was already on the wane as
it has been for months
then you just manufacture a feeling of
crisis
okay so yesterday the public health
experts decided based on no
new data none that everything i've been
saying for the past several months is
correct
okay now it's very important to note
here the timing again
all of this data has been widely
available for months it's been available
since february and march
and we have known since even before then
that if you had coven
and you had developed antibodies too
covid you were not going to infect
anyone and yet everybody was busy
screaming at rand paul suggesting that
if rand paul stripped off his mask he
was going to infect people
that was not true okay rand paul
happened to be correct about that
i know because i was talking to people
who were actual epidemiologists i was
talking to people who are actual doctors
like dr marty mccary over at johns
hopkins university
and yet we were told by the public
health experts the institutional
know-it-alls that you had to listen to
them even if what they were saying
was not in consonance with the science
this is what happens when you have an
idol worshiping society
when people have determined that there
are people who know more than everybody
else and their expertise this cult of
expertise
has to be paid attention to even when
the experts are speaking not from their
own expertise but via politics and you
can tell
because experts are able to show their
work experts are able to tell you why
they think the things that they do
every day on this show for months we've
been playing clips of rashabalensky
unable to explain our own policies
we've been playing clips four months of
fauci being unable to explain
what the hell he's talking about and
then if you say that
then your social media bettors shut you
down because you're not speaking in
consonance with the cdc well the cdc was
not speaking in continents with science
how do we know because again none of the
data changed they changed all their
standards yesterday and the reason they
changed all their standards yesterday
to tell people who were vaccinated that
now finally they could unmask had
nothing to do with science
it had nothing to do with data it had to
do with the fact that joe biden had a
terrible couple of weeks politically
it had to do with the fact that
inflation is starting to hit and hit
really hard and not enough people are in
the workforce
and joe biden has to encourage people to
get back into the workforce because if
we don't have enough people
back in the workforce going back into
their regular lives inflation is going
to spiral out of control
that's what this has to do with okay so
the white house's new announcement the
sort of triumphal announcement you can
take off masks
what it really exposes is not that we
beat covid we beat coveted months ago
what it really exposes is that so much
of this has been politically driven and
remains
politically driven and if you ask me for
my outcome from this
who i trust and who i don't i'll tell
you who i trust big pharma who actually
came up
with the actual solution to this thing
i'll tell you who i don't trust the
government sources who lied to you every
step of the way
and i don't mean that they made mistakes
making mistakes is understandable
in the early days of the pandemic there
were a lot of mistakes made
understandable it was a novel
coronavirus we didn't know all that much
about it
but then it became overt lying and we've
had overt lying for months on
end and that becomes clear when finally
they tell the truth okay so yesterday
the white house puts out an announcement
via twitter in the middle of the day
big news from the cdc if you're fully
vaccinated you do not need to wear a
mask indoors or outdoors in most
settings
we've gotten this far whether you choose
to get vaccinated or wear a mask please
protect yourself until
we get to the finish line okay so here's
the thing even the cdc guidance is
stupid because the cdc guidance says
that if you're vaccinated you still have
to wear a mask if you go on a plane for
example
why why there's no reason for it
they say if you're on public transit you
still have to wear a mask they say
that if there are stores that ban you
from coming inside without a mask
even if you're vaccinated that that's
perfectly okay as well
they say that if you're in a doctor's
office that you're supposed to still
wear a mask even if you're fully
vaccinated
okay this is all stupidity now some of
this is rooted
in another level of ideology which is
how do we tell who's vaccinated and who
isn't and if we remove the mask rules
then
what if unvaccinated people take
advantage of this to unmask
along with the vaccinated people and the
answer is if you are vaccinated
you should not care nancy pelosi said
that she is not going to change the
rules on the house floor she said until
everybody is vaccinated i'm not going to
change the rules on the house floor
why everybody there's had the
opportunity to be vaccinated if they
don't want to be vaccinated that's a
them problem there's a small subgroup of
people
who do have a problem that small
subgroup of people are people who
literally cannot get the vaccine i'm not
talking about it's unavailable to them
because the vaccines are available to
everybody at this point
even if you have to drive a little bit
okay the the vaccines
there are some people who can't get them
for actual medical reasons
okay for those people there are n95s
available for those people their masks
available
they have to protect themselves
understood but the notion that the rest
of society is supposed to continue
masking up and not going to work
is ridiculous okay so even the cdc's
current standards make no sense
but again the the reason that i'm rather
ticked off this morning
is because the people who claim to speak
in the name of science never did
and now that they are speaking in the
name of the science they claim they were
always speaking in the name of the
science
so they're retconning history they lied
to you for months now they're telling
you the truth
and because they're telling you the
truth today they're suggesting they were
telling you the truth all along
and that is untrue this is all politics
the experts are not interested
in conveying you to the data they're not
interested in conveying to the science
they are interested in what gets joe
biden where he needs to go
and if they and joe biden was stuck in a
sort of catch-22 where the coveted
pandemic had to be extended
in order for him to get his jollies in
terms of policy and then
it turns out that his policy jollies
were undercutting the health of the
the american economy and he was feeling
the blowback then he has to shift one or
the other right either he has to shift
his policy or he has to shift
the coveted pandemic talk or both and
that's exactly what you are seeing right
now this has nothing to do with science
and everything to do with politics we'll
get to more of it in just
one second first let us talk about the
fact that my kids wake me up
unbelievably early in the morning every
single morning
and there's one product that gets me
through i'm talking of course about
black
rifle coffee black rifled coffee is
delivering your daily dose of freedom
one delicious cup at a time black rifle
coffee company is a veteran-owned coffee
company
serving premium coffee to people who
love america veteran ceo
and founder evan hafer he spent over
seven years on the ground overseas with
u.s special forces
and is a cia contractor black rifle is
continually committed to supporting
veteran
law enforcement and first responder
causes in our country and overseas
courageous frontline workers risk their
lives every day to protect ours
inspired by their hard work and
dedication to protecting our communities
black rifle makes it their mission
to give back to those who serve however
they can throughout may
black rifle is rallying behind leo law
enforcement officers
firefighters first responders active
duty military and other frontline
workers by spotlighting local heroes
through community nominations donating
coffee
to keep front lines caffeinated and
giving back to organizations that
support
our nation's heroes head on over to
blackriflecoffee.com
shapiro use promo code shapiro to get 20
off your purchase and your first coffee
club order that is blackriflecoffee.com
shapiro promo code shapiro yesterday
rochelle valencia who just
three weeks ago based on no data at all
was suggesting that doom
was on the way rashel wolenski who less
than a week ago
was suggesting you needed to continue
masking even if you'd been vaccinated
despite all of the data this public
health expert right science has an
institution versus sciences of process
rachelle malenski she says you know what
now you can take off your mask
anyone who is fully vaccinated can
participate
in indoor and outdoor activities large
or small without wearing a mask or
physical distancing
if you are fully vaccinated you can
start doing the things that you had
stopped
doing because of the pandemic once you
are fully vaccinated
two weeks after your last dose you can
shed
your mass okay and then she says you
know what you know what drove this what
drove this is science of course
now here's the thing have i been any new
studies nope not a one
not a one we knew this months ago months
ago this is uh precisely what i was
trying to to get out with the the
director of the ctc dr olinsky when i
spoke to her after
um so and she she was asked twice about
this during the conference once but once
by katelyn
and she sort of dodged it saying you
know there's going to be more guidance
forthcoming on this
the science sort of sort of applies
still here it still applies right the
science is
indoors large gathering or small
gathering if everyone is vaccinated
uh you don't need to wear masks okay
sanjay gupta is in the science the
science chan
the science didn't change anything okay
the science has been known
it's been known you know how i know that
because i've been saying it for months
and every time you say oh you're a
science denier no i'm a scientific
institution denier i don't believe that
these quote unquote institutions have a
monopoly
on the process of science and they
demonstrate they're
they're unverifiable nonsense every
single day
it's incredible to me okay it just
pisses me off that for months we were
told
that you were somehow putting people at
risk when you were not
they this administration undermined
vaccines this administration for months
had your biden out there telling a week
ago he was telling you it was patriotic
to mask up
after you and your friend were
vaccinated if you were sitting in close
contact you should ask
because you're patriotic he said that
last week
okay and now magically you can take off
the masks forever okay the answer is
had nothing to do with science yes he
created vaccine hesitancy
yes he undermined the american economy
yes he was lying to you they were all
lying to you okay you'll remember that
just a couple of weeks ago
maybe a week ago there was a a cdc
masking chart that was put out right it
was supposed to change the standards
for what you can do if you're fully
vaccinated and it said that if you were
outdoors you could unmask if you were
fully vaccinated
and even if and then they said that if
you're fully vaccinated
you still had to wear a mask if you went
to a crowded outdoor event like a live
performance parade or sports event
and everything indoors you're supposed
to mask and you'll remember i went
through this chart in detail
i went through every line of this chart
and i said everything on the right hand
side of this chart is a lie
go back and watch the tape everything
that says fully vaccinated people that
you're not supposed to do it's a law you
can do all of these things and you don't
need to ask for any of them
i said this two weeks ago okay and then
and then we were so worried about social
media that youtube
was going to give us like check marks
and take down our videos
because this is what social media does
it had nothing to do with facts okay so
here here's the new cdc graphic by the
way oh wait it looks exactly like what i
told them to do go back and look at the
tape i liter i
honestly we should pull the clip of me
saying what this chart should look like
versus what the chart now looks like
they are identical
okay it's the whole thing is ridiculous
on its face
it's ridiculous so anthony fauci came
out
yesterday he said you know what we have
to get rid of restrictions so people can
get
like it can feel like they're getting
back to normal what i i have a question
where is anthony faucian what have you
done with him where is the real anthony
fauci where did you get this impostor
here's anthony fauci saying maybe this
will cause people to get vaccinated
this is the same administration that
refused to acknowledge that you could go
out and live life after getting
vaccinated
this is the same administration that
undermined vaccines
by suggesting that we had to pause the
jnj rollout because there were six cases
out of six
million people who had blood clots and
here's anthony fauci
then you know maybe maybe this will
encourage people to get vaccinated you
know he's been saying this for months
right here he's got two thumbs and
saying that this guy
here's anthony fauci what we're doing
now with the relaxation
of the restrictions on people who have
vaccinated is trying to get back
to a degree of normality which people
who get vaccinated deserve
to have that that's been one of the
things that's been the concern
saying if i get vaccinated what
difference is it going to make my life
hasn't really changed that much
well now your life is going to change
that much for people
who are not vaccinated this might be
an incentive for them to get vaccinated
okay
so it's amazing now he's saying what is
scientifically true
so is he lying before is he lying now
for the left amazingly they're saying
he's lying now
the left is like well i don't even know
why they're saying we should take off
our mess maybe you should
wear our masks forever first of all let
me just say this you are a
sheep you're a sheep if you are wearing
a mask now
if you're wearing a mask and you've been
vaccinated it's because you're a sheep
there is
you're free you're free to be a sheep
it's a free country but you are
you are living life in fear for no
reason these vaccines are unbelievably
effective
even your own garbage administration is
telling you that okay but
anthony fauci i love this the flip in
time is just incredible i mean
you could you're getting whiplash here
here's anthony fauci saying you know
this is a step in the right direction
yeah we noticed
i wouldn't go so far as to say it's
essentially over i think this is a
very important step in the direction of
trying to get back to some degree of
normality
because this is something that everyone
has had on their mind you know i'm
vaccinated
when can i start doing things a little
bit more in the normal trend
and being able to go around without a
mask indoors as well as outdoors
is really a big step in that direction
so i wouldn't want to declare victory
prematurely but i'm saying
this is clearly a step in the direction
that we want to go unbelievable by the
way how bad is the whiplash here here's
how bad the whiplash was
yesterday afternoon they announced that
cdc announced that if you
had been vaccinated you could take off
your mask just before that joe biden had
had a meeting
in the white house with the house
minority leader and the house majority
leader
and the and the speaker of the house and
and all the various
leaders of the various parties everybody
in the room had been vaccinated
and there's a picture going around of
every single person in the room wearing
a mask
and so a senior biden advisor andy
slavitt
who's been wrong on three quarters of
this stuff andy slavitt a coveted
advisor to biden was asked
so why was joe biden masked he is
vaccinated everyone in the room is
vaccinated here was andy slavitzander's
answer yesterday
yesterday morning before the cdc
announced that by the way you can take
off the mask
i'm not sure that the president is the
average uh person i
i personally think there's a lot of
protections around the president why
does he need lots of secret service
agents why does he
why do they you know belt and suspender
everything with the president because
he's a very important person
and i think you shouldn't take your mark
just by what you see in the oval office
i think most people
if you're indoors around other people
that are vaccinated cd says it's okay
um and i think you should listen to the
cdc on that i mean it's unreal so
basically he has no rationale whatsoever
but they were still promulgating this
crap knowing that it was crap and then
the cdc changed its standard
later in the day again all this had to
do with the fact that joe biden is a
giant failure of a president
and because he's a failure of a
president he needs to declare early
victory remember the original date they
were going to declare victory was july
4th
why because they wanted the symbolic
victory on july 4th and because they
were hoping that before july 4th they
could ram through these trillions of
dollars in spending then it turns up the
inflation blew up
it turns out that joe manchin and
kristen cinema weren't going to go along
with it and so joe biden had a choice i
can continue to foster
this this world-beating giant spending
agenda
and blow out the economy in the process
or i can walk this thing back a little
bit
and so he decided yesterday that it was
time for a new news cycle that's what
this really is about don't talk about
manipulation of science on behalf of
politics this is it
okay we're gonna get to more of this in
just one second because again this
whiplash is just extraordinary
i mean everybody needs a neck
examination after this one first
let's talk about ways you can keep your
family safe and secure you've heard me
share about how important the second
amendment is to the foundation of the
country
you might even be one of the over 5
million citizens who purchased a firearm
for the first time in 2020.
if you've taken that first step of
protecting yourself with a firearm the
next step in your personal protection
plan
should be considering body armor for
yourself and your family if somebody
comes in your house it's not just a
matter of having a weapon to defend
yourself
it'd be good if you had some sort of
device to prevent you from being harmed
shopping for body armor may seem like
something you never thought you'd have
to do you may not know where to begin
in fact you might not even know you can
buy body armor this is where ar 500
armor comes in
ar500 armor.com makes buying body armor
easy approachable and affordable in fact
with ar500 armor.com you buy it online
you have it shipped straight
to your house ar 500 armor has multiple
packages
built for people just like you who are
looking for varying levels of protection
they make the shopping process simple
and approachable their team is always
willing to help answer
any questions that you might have also
the people over there they have the same
values you do they're law abiding folks
who just want to defend themselves
defend their families best of all they
put together some packages specifically
for listeners of the daily wire there's
something for everyone at ar500
armor.com go to air500 armor.com ben see
all their promotions and special pricing
running right now you can use codeben
for 20 off anything else in their store
i know the people who
run the company they are good family
folks plan right now for how to protect
yourself and your family for the future
get yourself the body armor we trust
from ar500 armor
at ar 500 armor dot com slash ben again
visit air 500 armor dot com slash ben
use code ben at checkout
for 20 off okay so and the whiplash can
give you a real headache here
joe biden and kamala harris made their
first maskless appearance yesterday
they should have done this months ago
that would have encouraged people to get
the vaccine instead they decided to
delay for months because they wanted the
feeling of panic then it turns out that
the feeling of panic wasn't
actually forwarding their legislative
agenda in any serious fashion all it was
doing was artificially
lowering the the labor market and
creating inflation so they decided to
reverse themselves yesterday
man watching joe biden walk it's always
like man please keep your feet
cool and you got a great smile
oh so much happiness huh ah we took off
our masks
oh amazing amazing and of course the
media ate all of this up
cnn's allison cameron should i was
welling up oh the tears the cheers
what was it them lying to you that had
you welling up because um presumably
alice in camarada like pretty much
everybody else at cnn has
and everybody else in america has had
the opportunity to get vaccinated
so um why was this making you well up as
opposed to you know
once you got the vaccine you could go
back to your regular life which we all
knew
months ago again this wasn't a secret
they were just lying here's allison
camerata
i found myself welling up when when dr
walensky was talking and she said it's
an we have an exciting announcement and
i still find myself welling up
even right now because you know you and
i
talked every morning you know during the
past year
about how many more americans were going
to die
you know what was going to happen were
we going to make it to the vaccines were
we all going to survive what was going
to happen
and you know 580 000 americans didn't
make it to this day
you know this day that they say that we
can throw these away that we've all been
clinging to
uh it's so moving the media's moved now
it might have been their job to ask
questions for like you know the last
several months about why it is that we
shouldn't have been
taking off the masks months ago but they
were too busy kissing ass
because this is mostly what they do by
the way they're not just whiplashing on
this
they're also whiplashing on schools so
anthony fauci again where is anthony
fausch what have you done with him
yesterday he was like it's time to open
the schools come fall we got to open
these schools
yes some of us have been knowing this
since like last year
like last summer my kids have been in
school since october the hell are you
talking like
you're a little late on this one i
believe the school should be
open five days full blast just the way
it was before
that that we really have to do that by
the time we get to the fall
and if the kids are and if the kids are
vaccinated no masks required right
right well again i'm gonna leave that to
the cdc to make that decision but i
would think that that certainly would be
an option
if the children are vaccinated not to
have a mask it's unbelievable like i'm
gonna leave that to the cdc you could
just say it
you could by the way you know how bad
this was for the democrats you know how
bad this issue was turning for the
democrats randy weingarten of the
american federation for teachers
even she came out and she's like yeah
you know maybe we should just reopen the
schools
it was her fault she was the one talking
to the cdc and having them change their
standards to slow the reopening
the blowback against democrats because
of their coveted alarmism
in the post-vaccination era it must have
been serious for them to reverse this
fast
it really must have been okay in one
second we'll get to randy weingarten
reversing herself because it is pretty
incredible again the entire reversal
here it is driven by politics
first let's talk about your sleep
quality so helix sleep
they are the people who keep me going
because let's be real about this my kids
wake me up at all hours of the night
when i get back on that mattress i need
to sleep i need a mattress made just for
me
this is where helix sleep comes in helix
sleep has a quiz that takes just two
minutes to complete matches your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you
why would you buy a mattress made for
someone else with helix you're getting a
mattress that you know will be perfect
for the way you sleep
everybody's unique helix knows that so
they have several different mattress
models to choose from
they have soft medium firm mattresses
mattresses great for cooling you down if
you sleep hot
even a helix plus mattress for plus size
folks it's been awesome getting unboxing
videos from so many of you it really is
cool when we got our helix slip mattress
you just open up the box it inflates
right in front of you
pop it on the bed frame you're good to
go go to helixsleep.com
take their two minutes sleep because
they will match you to a customized
mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life they've got
a 10-year warranty you get to try out
for 100 nights risk-free they'll even
pick it up for you if you don't love it
but you will
helix is offering up to 200 bucks off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners at helixsleep.com
we've got the personalized mattress
you should too go check them out
helixsleep.com
to get started okay so even randy
weingarten is now shifting on this stuff
here's randy weingarten the head of the
american federation for teachers
saying yeah maybe we should open up the
schools now
today 97 of schools across the country
are open for in-person learning either
full
or part time conditions have changed
we can and we must reopen schools
in the fall for in-person teaching
learning and support and we must keep
them open
fully and safely five days
a week unbelievable unbelievable
i mean seriously the this lady was
single-handedly responsible for the cdc
redrawing its standards to not reopen
schools before the end of the school
year because we're basically
at the end of the school year right now
and now she's like yeah by the f and she
announced it the same day as fauci
this is all politics these folks are not
public health experts they're
they're politicians with white coats
and sometimes not even with white coats
it's just absurd
and meanwhile jill biden was out there
celebrating as well she said she got
real weird here this
got strange what does that mean to the
people of west virginia
that means get vaccinated that's what it
means everybody get vaccinated
and you feel free yeah we felt free yeah
the first time we knew what to do we
feel naked
right um yeah joe
the the greatest of all doctors
all right well here's the thing once you
have set this train in motion
the we're scared of real life train the
don't examine the science just listen to
the experts train
once you've set in into a chain of
effect a feeling of incipient doom and
panic
it's very difficult to roll that back
and that is what you are seeing today so
it doesn't matter that the biden
administration
finally caught up with the science
months late
the left can't swivel on a dime that way
and so they continue to panic
you're seeing this all over left is
twitter you're seeing it in the media
people like
well yeah but if we if we take off our
mass and we're vaccinated won't that
encourage the unvaccinated
to unmask well here's the thing once
you're vaccinated
you shouldn't care you're vaccinated
you're safe
you're good if somebody else chooses not
to get the vaccine
that would be a them problem that's a
problem that they're going to have to
deal with
i'm not talking again about people who
don't have the ability to get a vaccine
because of a health problem those people
should be given n95s or kn 95s and they
should make themselves safe and however
they can however they can but it is none
of your business whether somebody else
has had a vaccine or not once you
have had the vaccine that is the entire
point
and all of this is really just an excuse
for virtue signaling because the mask
over the past year
has become a virtue signaling device
which was always insane to me i
always said from the very beginning i
said if masks are useful
you should wear them in public places if
you're not vaccinated to prevent
yourself and others from getting this
disease
and then i said once you're vaccinated
you don't need the mass because this is
all what the data said right i just
followed the data
not the public health experts who
weren't experts they were lying to you
and now you've got the same public
health experts being like i'm alarmed by
this this is
what this is just crazy okay because it
turns out that this is a mentality
it's a way of life it's an attitude
toward life it is a risk-averse attitude
toward life that is unjustifiable
under current data the people right now
on the left who continue to maintain the
idea that you're supposed to mask
mandate
this is because they've entered a world
in which they like being told what to do
that is all this is so cnn's leanna
wench says i was shocked that the cdc
came out with this announcement shocked
why we've known four months that once
you're vaccinated you're good to go
frankly i was shocked by this
announcement i think they went from one
extreme to
another and the major step that's
missing here is
how do we know that people are telling
the truth we talked in the last hour
about the honor code i mean if you're
going to the grocery store maybe you're
fully vaccinated
you take off your mask of the grocery
store but who's going to be checking to
see if
others are also vaccinated so what does
that mean
if i'm bringing my son my four-year-old
who's not fully vaccinated
now he's going to be in a grocery store
potentially exposed to people who are
not vaccinated who could be
of danger to him and so i guess i am
kind of befuddled as to where this
guidance came from if you're worried
about your four-year-old son i have an
idea he can continue to mask
or alternatively he can stay home when
you go to the grocery store it's none of
your business whether other people
are vaccinated once you yourself are
vaccinated and
again this is rooted in the idea that is
true as i've been saying all along
that kids who are young are not in
serious danger from covid because
statistically speaking they are not in
serious danger from covid
and right now in the united states if
you're above the age of 12 you can get a
vaccine
right now in the united states the fda
issued emergency use authorization
for people who are 12 to 15 years old as
though there's some sort of public
health emergency to justify
12 to 15 year olds getting coveted
and the grand number of americans under
the age of 18 who have gotten and died
who have died of covet is i believe
lower than a thousand
out of hundreds of thousands of people
who have been in fact millions of people
who have been infected
okay but they can't let go of it they're
not gonna let go of it and that's the
great irony here joe biden has made his
bed now he's gonna have to sleep in it
because it turns out all these blue
areas
the ones that he wants to reopen to prop
up his failing economy
they're not going to he went too far he
has trained them
in the art of fear the entire media have
spent the last year training you to be
afraid
and now that there's not at the
beginning there was justification for
being afraid now
that there is very little justification
for being afraid
it's too it's too late they're having
trouble shifting the new york times has
a piece today
titled hundreds of epidemiologists
expected mask wearing in public for at
least a year
well i wonder why they would have
expected that maybe it's because anthony
fauci said until next mother's day
he said that's what nine ten days ago
and i was like
take off the mask these these jokers
when federal health officials said on
thursday that fully vaccinated americans
no longer needed to wear masks in most
places
it came as a surprise to many people in
public health it also was a stark
contrast with the views of a large
majority of epidemiologists
surveyed in the last two weeks by the
new york times in the informal survey 80
said they thought americans would need
to wear masks in public indoor places
for at least another year
just five percent said people would no
longer need to wear masks and door by
the summer
yes because the epidemiologists are all
part of a group think
they had nothing to do that's a that's a
recommendation okay that recommendation
was not based on the science
hey by the way it is also true that many
of the things they've been telling you
for a long time
are lies about where you are going to
get covered abc news has this today
quote pars gyms and restaurants those
were just a few settings health experts
warn could become hotbeds of kova 19
as states began reopening in the spring
and summer of 2020.
yet public data analyzed by abc news
appears to tell a different story
the data from states across the country
suggests specific outbreak settings
including bars gyms restaurants nail
salons barbershops and stores
only accounted for a small percentage if
any
of the new outbreaks after the pandemics
initial wave in 2020
while experts believe that mitigation
measures like reduced capacity gradual
reopening and mass scoring
contributed to keeping outbreak numbers
low they say more could have been done
to push those numbers down further and
make testing and tracing
more robust based on abc news's analysis
of public data of all coveted cases in
four states in dc
those outbreak settings accounted for
less than five percent
of all covet 19 cases in those states
so in other words all the places you
were told you couldn't go all the
workplaces you were told you couldn't go
you couldn't go to the gym you couldn't
go to a bar you couldn't go to a
restaurant you couldn't do any of those
things that accounted for a tiny
percentage
of covet transmission but some of us
ron desantis was saying this in florida
for a year and he was castigated for it
they lied to you they are continuing to
lie to you for political purposes
why would you trust them ever just look
straight to the data
and some of these states are not going
to reopen according to the new york
times
as federal health officials on thursday
cleared the way for americans who are
fully vaccinated against kova to drop
mass scoring in most situations
some states lifted mass mandates while
others took a more cautious approach
on thursday the governors of
massachusetts new york new jersey north
carolina and virginia
and the mayors of new york city in
washington dc said they were taking the
new guidance from the cdc under
advisement
before adopting it ah they know better
than the cdc now so when the cdc was
hawkish on mask squaring
then they were all with the cdc when cdc
is like oh yeah by the way here's the
signs
like nah we're not going to do it in
deference to local authorities the cdc
said vaccinated people must continue to
abide by existing state local or tribal
laws and regulations and follow local
rules for businesses and workplaces
governor ron desantis
being the best governor in the country
already has issued an executive order
preemptively pardoning people who don't
abide by state and local
mass mandates because they are no longer
necessary
governor andrew cuomo had the temerity
to say that the state had always relied
on the facts and the science to guide us
throughout the worst of the pandemic and
that he would review the new federal
health guidelines with the state health
department mayor bill de blasio called
the shift in guidance a monumental day
but said the city would would be
reviewing the new rules as masks will
still be important for schools
public transportation doctors offices
and more
okay all this is a joke i'm sorry this
is a joke and and one and
you guys are all trained in being cheap
that's all that's happened here
all of these and if you if you listen to
these bill de blasios and andrew cuomo
who presided over the worst
case of outbreak in the united states if
you listen to these people
as opposed to the actual science at this
point i don't know what to tell you
you've been you're being an ignoramus
you're being a fool
but the good news is that anthony fauci
is there to defend your foolishness
say anthony fauci says you know you have
to stop giving side eye to people who
keep wearing masks
this is hilarious so we've been treated
to a year of if i'm outdoors a thousand
feet from everybody
i've been treated to to morons dressed
in
grim reaper costumes chastising me for
not wearing a mask
outdoors a thousand feet for everybody
on florida beaches now i've been treated
jogging by by people who are masked
while jogging for no reason staring at
you giving you giving you the evil
glance even though the science didn't
back
what they were suggesting okay and now
there are a bunch of us who are like
okay well if you're vaccinated there's
no reason for you to be wearing a mask
what are you doing
and fat she's like we shouldn't shame
people for continuing grow our mask we
shouldn't i mean
that would be intolerant weird how the
intolerance only runs one way how about
this how about the intolerance runs
unbe we can tolerate whatever it's a
free country but
put that aside what should our attitude
be toward people who are masking
uselessly
honestly an attitude of pity because
these are people who have been
treated to mental disturbance courtesy
of the american federal government and
morons like anthony fouch and
richarlinsky it's unbelievable
i was wondering if you had anything to
say to people who have been vaccinated
and still want to wear masks in
situations that the cdc
says are low risk is anything wrong with
that and should people be
side eyeing them no not at all
i mean people have to make their own
personal choice
as we know the risk is extremely low of
getting infected
if you're vaccinated or whether you're
indoors or outdoors
but there are those people who don't
want to take that bit
of a risk and there's nothing wrong with
that and they shouldn't be criticized
oh they shouldn't be criticized it turns
out you can criticize people for
standing out in the middle of nowhere
not wearing a mask
but you should definitely not criticize
people for being fully vaccinated
standing in the middle of nowhere
wearing a mask
oh the public health experts the tough
science so much sciencing
okay in a second we'll explain why it is
that the biden administration decided to
do this now and the answer of course
has to do with the fact that this is the
worst political week for joe biden since
his inauguration we'll get some more of
this in one second first
let's talk about the fact that when you
are sitting in an office you need a
comfortable chair you don't think about
it all that much but then you get up
and you feel it in your back right you
feel it it's just you feel
yucky because you were sitting in a
chair that wasn't that great instead
why not get the best chair available i'm
talking about the x chair
the secret is not only their patented
dynamic variable lumbar support
which offers unbelievable lumbar support
to your lower back but also thanks to
their new
hmt technology you can also get heat and
massage therapy while you are sitting at
your desk which is just awesome
instead of your old uncomfortable office
chair now you can look forward to
spending hours sitting in the ultimate
therapeutic massager
the xhmt delivers heat and massage
technology right to your core helping
you increase blood flow muscle recovery
and energy all perks that make working
from home
or the office a joy x chair is on sale
right now for a hundred bucks off
go to xchairshapiro.com right now that's
the letter x
chair shapiro shapiro.com or call one
eight four four
four x chair extra has a 30-day
guarantee of complete comfort you can
finance your purchase for as little as
30 bucks a month go to externshapiro.com
right now use codex wheels for free
x wheel blade casters xchairshapiro.com
we tell you
the extra has been passed around the the
producer's room there's basically a
fistfight every morning for who gets to
sit in the extra it is that good go
check it out right now xchurshapiro.com
use codex wheels for free xwheel
bladecasters xchairshapiro.com
right now alrighty in just a second
we'll get to the reason why the biden
administration has suddenly and
radically shifted its
guidance with regard to masking first
it's that glorious time of the week when
i give a shout out to a daily war member
today it's andrew loradi on twitter who
understands the importance of proper
front yard signage in the pic two
examples of the world's greatest
beverage vessel flank the sides of a
poster that reads
in this house we believe that if you
post semantically overloaded left-wing
tautologies on your lawn
to signal your unearned moral
superiority you are a douchebag
yes this was my recommended sign and i
truly appreciate that somebody took me
up on it andrew writes hey ben shapiro i
might need you guys to start working on
a larger tumblr for all these tiers
at real daily where hashtag left to
stare tumblr you're exactly right
and with a sign like that uh i do
recommend a ring doorbell
camera to catch all the action on your
front yard thanks for all the shout out
and thanks for being a daily wire member
also
if you've been looking to brush up on
your understanding of authoritarianism
in order to fight the leftist power grab
currently underway
i have a perfect book for you it's by me
so this is self-serving but it also
happens to be true it's called the
authoritarian moment
okay this book is really important i
wrote it to help americans understand
that the true threat to the country
is not a bunch of drugs and morons doing
what they did on january 6
the true threat to the country is the
authoritarian takeover of
every major institution in america by a
left that seeks to strip you of your
individual rights
and to quash descent i explain how every
one of these institutions was
renormalized there's a full chapter on
how scientific institutions were turned
into weapons for the woke and the book
is really designed on how to fight back
because you don't
they're they're how how these
institutions became the way they are
is really important understand if you
want to roll that back so if you want to
preserve your individual rights and
protect the ones you love from mob rule
go check out my book today the
authoritarian moment is now available
for pre-order at amazon barnes noble or
any other major
bookseller also if you've been wondering
what it's like to watch candace owens
drop truth bombs live
now is your chance to find out tickets
to join candace's live studio audience
in nashville are free
they are indeed free but only to all
access members and limited to her monday
tapings throughout
the month of june it gets better get 20
off in all access membership right now
by using the code all access at checkout
just head on over to dailywire.com
tickets to secure your spot hurry though
seating is limited candace's show is in
high demand so the spots are going to go
pretty much immediately
head on over to dailywire.com tickets to
be part of an experience so beautiful
it would bring tears to a left to size
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so why exactly is the biden
administration reversing itself
on whether you can unmask the answer is
because they have to distract from the
crappiest news cycle
that they have had really since biden's
inauguration so biden has been treated
to
just sycophantic drooling media coverage
since his inauguration and then this
week inflation hit
the border crisis continues to to
marinate we've got war in the middle
east
and all this is happening on the back of
a horrible employment report
so that's a really bad week for this
administration so now it's time to
inject some optimism by you know
actually saying the true thing that we
should have said
three months ago okay so over at the
border migrant children apparently are
still being stuck overnight on buses
according to nbc news
in a vast parking lot outside the kay
bailey hutchinson convention center
miners who migrated to the us without
their parents are waiting on buses to be
sent to live with relatives or sponsors
staying overnight eating and using all
the bathroom all within the confines of
the bus according to the owner of one of
the bus companies and advocates for the
children
in at least one case described to nbc
news a family says their 15 year old son
waited on buses from saturday to
wednesday
before beginning the long journey from
dallas to seattle
i mean so disaster area there's still
thousands of kids who are being held
in close quarters in the middle of uh of
apparently
you know the covered pandemic still
applies to migrants the good news is
that the dhs secretary apparently has
short-term memory loss he says he
doesn't remember saying
that migrants should come he did
he said i'm not saying migrants
shouldn't come i'm just saying they
shouldn't come right now
he was reminded of this and alejandro
marcus was like i don't remember saying
that
me who what you remember saying don't
you that
we're not telling you not to come those
are your words that you said in a press
conference
you you said that right i don't i don't
recall saying that i don't believe you
don't recall saying that that's correct
senator i
have never said we'd be happy to refresh
your memory for you and some questions
for the right i'm sure that that is
interesting news that i'm sure everyone
will
the secretary just said he he doesn't
have any memory
of making those comments that's
extraordinary senator
i have never said that the border is
open
okay nobody said he said the board is
open you just said i'm not saying don't
come
i'm just saying don't come right now
that's what mayorka said but he doesn't
remember it so that's good
meanwhile by the way the biden
administration will resume construction
of southern border wall levy
according to fox news u.s army corps of
engineers will restart construction on a
13.4 mile stretch of levy in the rio
grande valley
the decision reportedly follows pressure
from local residents and politicians to
mend
the incessant crossing surge priority
repairs are set to begin in six weeks to
prevent flooding followed by the
establishment of a concrete levee wall
fit with safety barriers in six
to nine months so yeah they're shoring
up the wall that that's apparently a
super bad wall weird so they've replaced
they've sort of reversed themselves on
that
meanwhile inflation is here according to
the new york times the central fact of
the american economy in mid-2021
is that demand for all sorts of goods
and services has surged but supplies are
coming back slowly with the economy
acting like a quickie machine that was
turned off for a year and has some rusty
parts
well actually the economy is acting like
you would expect it to act when you pay
people to stay home
and when you tell them it is unsafe to
go back to work the good news is that
the
biden administration has no idea what to
do with inflation i mean no clue so jen
sack he's like you know the inflation is
just a sign that everything is going
great
okay then crazy lady let's go with that
we've seen over the last couple of days
to your point
some reaction to the cpi numbers that
came out
just yesterday and you know our view on
that is it reflects the reality of an
economy that's rapidly
turning uh back on uh because of a
successful economic strategy and if you
dig into the data
there are a couple of factors at play
that i think people are
taking a look at now that we've dug into
the data more okay yeah the factors of
play
are that everybody had more savings at
the end of last year than they had at
the beginning of last year because the
government paid them because they had to
pay them to stay home
and then you just continued pumping
money into their pockets
and then you said you don't ever have to
go back to work basically because we'll
pay unemployment benefits all the way
through september
meanwhile elizabeth warren and the left
wing of the democratic party who really
rule the roost
they're saying yeah i'm delighted that
biden is governing like a radical
are you surprised at how progressive the
policies are
they're being proposed by the president
oh not surprised delighted
this is the good news you know this is
one of the best things i talk about this
in the book
putting out plans means they're there
for everybody
and they're there for us to share and
improve on and make
better but this seems like big
structural change and i'm sorry nobody
expected that from him
well all i can say is he ran on the most
progressive agenda in
decades okay some of us pointed this out
at the time but we were being gaslit by
the media that proclaimed that joe biden
was moderate here's the problem
all of this is starting to bear some
really really ugly fruit you've got the
inflation you've got the unemployment
numbers they're not great
and then you had people waiting in gas
lines by the way it turns out the
colonial pipeline just paid a 5 million
ransom to the hackers who hacked the
pipeline
which of course is going to incentivize
more people to hack pipelines when you
pay ransoms like this this is where the
u.s government really should have
stepped in and done something but
they didn't so i mean did the government
assure colonial pipeline that it would
backfill them if they paid the ransom
how exactly did this work
when bloomberg news asked joe biden if
he was briefed on the company's ransom
payment the president paused and then
said i have no comment on that
okay so all of this is going really well
plus joe biden continues to be an
utterly incoherent
boob i mean he just joe biden's war with
the teleprompter continues basically
it's now it's now rocky it's like joe
biden
is apollo creed and the teleprompter is
rocky and they just
keep having these repeat battles every
day i expect any moment that the
teleprompter is going to run up
the stairs of the philadelphia museum of
art and throw
its non-arms in the air because like the
continuing battle between joe biden and
the teleprompter is one of the most
fascinating battles in american public
life
i can't wait for for joe biden versus
the teleprompter part three when mr t
comes in he's like i pity the fool who
can't read the telepr anyway
here is here is joe biden battling the
teleprompter
the rule is very simple get vaccinated
or wear a mask until you do
it's vac said
[Music]
get vaccinated it's vac said or masked
it sounds like mike myers and so i
married an axe murderer
on love ed unvax
ed hey what what in the what in the
actual okay
and then that was that was the the first
joe biden versus the teleprompter
uh in that one they fought to a draw in
joe biden versus the teleprompter two
the teleprompter comes with a clear
knockout
now here's what drives the driver
in the states that are affected here's
it that you can do
the drivers don't panic number one
oh my god it's it's like i don't know do
you laugh or you cry
i mean really solid stuff there from
from the teleprompter teleprompter comes
with a clear victory right there that's
a tko
in like round two by the teleprompter
i need that again was that in english
play it again
now here's what drives
the driver in the states
that are affected here's it that you can
do the drivers
don't panic number one here's what
drivers should do
here's what drives the drivers in the
drive droovy in the ryan gosling movie
drive
drivers drive drewbin tran jubitzanin
right yeah everything is going
fantastically so
is it any wonder that the cdc reversed
itself yesterday
again if you want one of the great
themes during this pandemic has been
trust the experts
trust the people who know if you do
after this i don't know what to tell you
other than you're a fool
the experts were wrong a lot the experts
lied to you
a lot you were told that if you bucked
the experts because you actually looked
at the science
this is because you had done something
wrong instead you were just supposed to
believe
and follow and now you're supposed to
believe and follow this incoherent old
man
and his benightly corrupt institution
and and if you don't then you're a bad
person
it's it's ridiculous on its face it's
ridiculous but
again here's the thing i think that the
american public is going to buck against
this i think biden knows this too
it's the reason why he is trying to
reverse himself so fast i didn't reverse
themselves by saying we're going to
gradually
withdraw these mandates we're going to
give states permission to do this
instead they just came out and they said
if you're vaccinated you don't need to
wear a mask anymore
this was an attempt to shift the
narrative some of the media
decided to go along with it and cry like
allison camerata
and some of them are like i can't even
believe they're doing this i mean do we
feel safe out there
don't be conditioned to follow these
people instead
science it's a process it's not an
institution keep remembering that
okay meanwhile over in israel
the conflict continues israel pulled one
of the great maneuvers
in i've ever even heard of in military
history last night this is pretty
spectacular so here's what happened
last night israel announced that they
were going to be
invading gaza there was going to be a
ground invasion and this was not
unexpected considering the gaza fires as
i've said many times
they've been firing thousands of rockets
from populated areas right they
specifically do it from apartment
complexes they do it from the top of
apartment buildings they do it from
between apartment buildings they do it
from public streets
they hide behind children they put their
economic headquarters in hospitals they
put their military headquarters in
hospitals like this is what they do
they use rnwa funded schools as bases
for launching terrorist attacks in the
same way that they just use the al-aqsa
mosque
in order to launch a riot against
israeli police officers
okay so this is what kamas does it's
what palestinian islamic jihad does
is what the palestinian authority does
and so one of the big problems for
israel is that every time it retaliates
and tries to take out military targets
it ends up having to kill civilians
now that's because of hamas if you hide
behind a child while firing at somebody
and they return fire and hit the child
that's not on the person returning fire
that's on you you're the one who hid
behind the child you're the one who put
the child
in danger every civilian death in gaza
is on hamas
because none of this had to happen by
the way some 30 of rockets that hamas
has tried to fire into israel fell short
and fell into the gaza strip and killed
people in gaza
including children hamas doesn't care
because they're the worst people on
earth i mean truly
truly the worst human beings on the
planet
are hamas they're garbage so israel was
faced with this kind of difficult
situation
you have these rockets keeping your
state underground
for days at a time i mean this remember
this started way earlier this week
they're now on what day five of this
and so israel has to stop the rocket
fire they'd prefer not to kill civilians
because unlike hamas they actually don't
want to kill civilians
so what do they do so normally what they
have to do is a ground invasion right
they try to go in and they try to
separate the civilians from the military
members of the terror groups by going
essentially door to door house to house
they've been doing this for decades it's
called in israel this this is called
purity of arms israel has higher
standards for human rights
with regard to how its military behaves
than any other military on planet earth
and it is not particularly close israel
is extremely careful about this sort of
stuff
it's why they've been dropping dropping
so-called knock bombs
on top of buildings they know hamas is
in these buildings
they drop a bomb on top of the building
that doesn't penetrate it just shakes
the building
so everybody knows get out and then they
bomb the building and this is how hamas
escapes by the way
israel phones apartment complexes and
tells them get out before they bomb the
places which is why hamas leaders are
able to escape
so israel takes the shot when it has the
shot and it doesn't take the shot
sometimes even when it does have the
shot if they're afraid that civilians
are in the way
so they said there there were sets of
sending ground forces and everybody sort
of expected this they'd called up 5000
reservists
they were getting ready to move and last
night the idf put out a tweet saying
that idf air and ground troops are
currently attacking the gaza strip and
this was taken
by the hamas terrorists as news that the
israeli ground troops were about to go
in
on the ground and fight it out street to
street and house to house
well hamas has a series of extensive
terror tunnels and these are tunnels
that go from area to area and house to
house
they have tunnels that go under the
border and into israel they've tried to
use them to attack israeli civilians
before
so all the hamas terrorists or at least
many of them the first wave of hamas
terrorists
they went into the terror tunnels to
hide from the israelis
right again a common gorilla tactic they
went into these terror tunnels because
then they're not there when the israelis
show up where are they they're
underground
okay there's only one thing israel knew
this israel faked the ground invasion
they said israel the idf released that
statement
that air and ground troops are currently
attacking in the gaza strip
this caused the hamas terrorists to go
into the terror tunnels and israel then
proceeded to bomb
the terror tunnels from the air which is
just the greatest thing i've ever heard
no one could deserve this more ritually
than terrorists who fire rockets at
civilian populations
according to the jerusalem post at about
9 pm on thursday night the idf began
assembling ground forces along the
border with the gaza strip
some armored and infantry battalions
joined the artillery batteries that had
been deployed days earlier to pan hamas
and islamic jihad targets
earlier in the day the idf said that a
ground offensive was on the table as a
viable option for the continuation of
operations guardians of the wall
the idf was hitting it hard at hamas and
islamic she had targets from the air but
on the ground
they would be expected to cause even
more damage albeit with greater risk to
israeli forces
prime minister benjamin netanyahu made
his contribution he said thursday the
campaign against hamas was far from over
and more israeli action was coming
at midnight the idf spokesperson's
english department tweeted the idf air
and ground troops are currently
attacking in the gaza strip
the foreign media jumped at the tweet
interpreting it to mean that israel was
sending ground forces into gaza
a major escalation in the current
operation websites of media outlets
around the world including the
washington post and abc reported the
incursion
israeli troops have entered the gaza
strip as conflict the palestinian
escalates israeli military says
was the tweet put out by the washington
post but there was no ground invasion
yes the idf had deployed troops along
the border but they didn't cross into
gaza
what did happen was in the air where 160
aircraft had assembled for a massive
bombing run over the gaza strip
their target was what the idf called
hamas metro an underground network of
tunnels where hamas stored its weapons
and used to move throughout gaza hidden
from israeli aircraft
the metro had been built in the years
after 2014 also known in israel as
operation protective edge it was a
network of dozens of kilometers of
tunnels that crisscrossed gaza
and provided safety from israeli aerial
incursions
according to reports due to the
deployment along the border and the news
coming out in the foreign media
hamas and islamic jihad sent their first
line of defense into the tunnels to
start taking up positions
these were the anti-tank missile teams
and mortar squads meant to strike an
incoming israeli ground forces
what they didn't know is there was no
ground defensive instead once they were
out of the tunnels they were exposed to
israeli aircraft
within minutes the metro attack went
ahead
how many hamas and islamic jihad
terrorists were killed in the operation
that remains
to be seen apparently the idf is still
evaluating the amount of damage they
were able to do
okay that is spectacular stuff that is
spectacular
stuff okay meanwhile debate has broken
out
inside the democratic party over all of
this you have the radical wing of the
democratic party this would be the squad
people like ilhan omar and people like
rashida talib and people like ayanna
pressley and alexander ocasio-cortez who
are just mimicking
anti-semitic slogans at this point
saying israel doesn't have the right to
defend itself
i mean truly this is what aoc said
yesterday so joe biden to his credit
really
not often that i think joe biden does
something credit worthy but yesterday
joe biden said the israeli reaction has
not been an overreaction which of course
is obvious and true
okay if you had hundreds of rockets
flying over your city you would also
expect your government to protect you by
killing the people who were firing the
rockets
here is joe biden defending israel one
of the things that
i have seen thus far is that
there has not been a significant
overreaction the question is
how
how we get to a point where they get to
a point where
there is a significant reduction
in the attacks particularly
the rocket attacks uh that are
indiscriminately fired
into population centers i'm good for
biden now how long can biden hold out
against his left flank
who knows probably not all that long
considering his previous previous
history of caving to everything the
radical left wants
yesterday alexander ocasio-cortez got
angry at joe biden for saying that
israel has a right to defend itself
which is the baseline level
of reality of course israel is a
sovereign state cannot allow its
citizens
to be put underground for weeks at a
time by islamic terrorists firing
rockets into the area
she tweeted out blanket statements like
these with little context or
acknowledgement of what precipitated the
cycle of violence
namely the expulsions of palestinians
and attacks on al-aqsa to humanize
palestinians and imply the us will look
the other way
at human rights violations it's wrong
okay first of all there's so many lies
in this it's difficult to know where to
start
this didn't start with the expulsion of
palestinians there was a 50-year ongoing
legal case
that was adjudicated and was not
effectuated by the israeli supreme court
there were no attacks on al-aqsa except
by the people who decided to use al-aqsa
as a staging point for riots
there were no expulsions six palestinian
families according to david harsanyi and
national review
might be evicted from their homes in
jura in a property dispute again that's
six
palestinian families shikshara is
thousands of people
okay this is it's insanity it's
ridiculous twenty percent of the arab
of the population of israel is arab the
al-aqsa mouse wasn't attacked but it was
other members of the squad as well
ilhan omar suggested that israeli
airstrikes killing civilians in gaza is
an act of terrorism
except for the fact that israel's been
attempting to minimize the amount of
death while hamas has been attempting to
maximize
the amount of death
i mean and rashida talib of course she
tweeted out yesterday the nakba never
ended nakba is the term
used by arabs to describe the
establishment of the state of israel
that was a disaster nakba means disaster
okay not
the israeli takeover of the west bank
and gaza strip in 67.
no the real disaster is that the jewish
state even exists according to rashida
talib
she makes this perfectly clear by the
way she says from jaffa in 1948
to sheikh jerusalem today we must
recognize the forced displacement and
violent
possession faced by palestinians for
over 70 years by the way jaffa in 1948
would be the establishment of the state
of israel
okay she believes that israel should be
just destroyed there's a part of the
democratic party that is so radical it's
attacking joe biden for the baseline
statement that israel can defend itself
against rocket attack
the question is how long will the
democratic party hold up against its own
radicals
the answer probably is not very long but
don't worry the media are covering liz
cheney versus kevin mccarthy or
something
meanwhile around his hands in florida he
came out very clearly he said israel has
a right to defend itself hamas is a
terrorist
organization which is clearly true i
have
friends over there who've been having to
hide out in in bomb shelters
overnight because of hamas which is a
terrorist group
raining down rockets on civilians and
make no mistake
hamas is a terrorist group they are at
fault on this
israel has every right to defend itself
against hamas and i think if you look at
what's going on here
really isn't so much about israel's
about hamas
trying to stake a claim uh to be the
leader
of the entire palestinian authority they
kind of have their little
uh place down in gaza where they uh
foment a lot of terrorism
absolutely correct here from ron
desantis meanwhile the pal
here's the unspoken story here of course
is the divided administration they're
saying the right things now with regards
to israel's right to defend itself
meanwhile they've been fostering this
okay they've been fostering this by
making overtures to iran
palestinian islamic jihad which is one
of the groups firing the rockets
they came out like over the last couple
of days and they're openly saying we got
these rockets from iran
which they did right israel didn't
realize that hamas had the ability to
fire rockets that could reach all the
way to hadera which is like central
israel like northern central israel
they got this technology from iran
meanwhile the united states is
attempting to foment some sort of deal
with the iranian terrorist government
here is members of palestinians and
palestinian islamic jihad saying this
openly
he says the mujahideen in gaza and in
use iranian weapons to strike
zionists
we buy our weapons with iranian money
an important part of our activities
under the supervision of iranian experts
the contours of the victories in
palestine as of late
were outlined with the blood of kasam
iranian blood you'll remember that was
the commander of iran's
terror access who was killed by the
trump administration
okay so iran is behind all of this it's
the reason why people are also
keeping an eye on the northern border of
israel hezbollah is an iranian-funded
terror group because
so far has stayed out because hezbollah
understands that because they are a
greater threat to israel
if they start firing rockets in israel
israel will just eviscerate them it
won't be like the gaza strip israel has
been engaging in pinpoint attacks
in the gaza strip specifically to avoid
civilian casualties
because hamas can kill israelis but they
don't provide an existential threat to
israel
hezbollah has 150 000 rockets pointed at
if they start firing those off israel
will just go off
and hezbollah knows this which is why
they've stayed out of the fight so far
instead they've been attempting these
sort of
proxy battles so apparently there are
mobs of people attempting to storm the
northern border right now of israel
they're mobs from jordan attempting to
come into the west bank
all of that will be stopped but again
the the notion that this administration
continues to try and
foster some sort of cooperation with
iran while iran is constantly fostering
terror around the region
demonstrates how wrong-headed their
policy is alrighty well
we have reached the end of this week's
broadcast but we will be back later
today with an additional hour of the ben
shapiro show first
you cannot forget to end your week by
checking out the andrew clavin show
drew's shows every friday he's got an
exciting evening planned for you as
always so
head on over to dailywire.com this
evening at 7 pm eastern tune in i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wiedowsky
editing is by adam sciavitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant is jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets started so come on over to the
andrew clavin show and laugh your way
through the fall of the republic with me
andrew clavin